hello everybody this is gary vaynerchuk
and this is my
120 on this friday november 2nd my uncle
joseph the crazy russian uncle's
birthday and i've got a lot to talk
about today but before i get into my
main rant about apple
is the apple getting sour i want to talk
about american gangster
probably the first movie i am jazzed up
to see in a long long time
hoping i'll get a chance to see that
tonight a big time movie i hope
i haven't read any previews nothing so
i'm looking forward to that what else do
i want to talk about
just a quick little shot facebook and
microsoft are poised to make their shot
at google i'm very curious about this
buzz in the air about maybe aol doing an
ad platform as well
you know google its entire success based
on the adsense
i mean there's other things but let's be
honest lots of money coming from their
ad network
advertising so it's gonna be very
interesting to see if facebook and
microsoft can combine
to make a real serious play yahoo was
never really able to do it so it's gonna
be with panama and all that other stuff
it could get very very very very
interesting
also i was thinking about one other
thing about politics it could be very
interesting you know youtube is the
leader but with
viddler and vimeo and bliptv i was
thinking that if
some candidate gets captured on film
doing something wrong that's going to
kind of
kill their candidacy in 2008 and that
will happen it's not when
but it's not will it or when it you know
it will happen
the question is going to become is is it
going to build another
social network website on video instead
of youtube because if it goes on one of
those sites
it can get a lot of exposure but let me
get into my main ram
it's all about apple i am really down on
them lately it's been a rough run for me
i hate the att and apple situation my
iphone
is very difficult to use the edge
network too slow things of that nature
and now the whole leopard thing i
installed leopard on my last uh laptop
i went offline and did all my emails on
the way to washington dc because i have
to do it went back on i'm basically
crashed
last night got a new macbook and my
brother aj got one he has to already
bring it back to the apple store today
apple is sour ring see you later